hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my episode 7 video the gift just like
you know all the other episodes of this
season that title is a metaphor for
several different things on the show as
well as a literal thing
lots of giving and receiving a very
unexpected amazing gifts so careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet and new round of the giveaway starts
now all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video just starting with top 7 WTF
moments number 7 Maester Aemon dunk and
egg shoutout
Maester Aemon in his fever dream as he
lay there dying starts calling out to
his brother Aegon Targaryen the fifth
that's egg from the duncan egg series
just one of the many spin-off series
that they could make a total I do I feel
like a Dunkin eggs spin-off series would
be really awesome they can even reuse
that mat that they used for the opening
title sequences because all the places
are still the same
Dunkin egg as a series mostly covers a
time when egg is growing up I did a
video for Aemon Targaryen mostly deals
with Aegon as an adult after he ascended
the throne two very different points in
time
eight grew up in the time after the
first Blackfyre rebellion the other
really cool thing about egg is that he
is Daenerys 'iz great-grandfather his
son was Jo Harris
his son was Aerys the second and then
obviously he had Daenerys on to number
six
Sansa asks Theon for help I feel like
anybody hoping things have gotten better
for Sansa in this episode were sorely
disappointed she has bruises all over
her clearly like what happened with her
last week has been happening with her
every single night since then I can hear
the outrage just pouring from the
internet she is basically getting the
fake Arya storyline from the book with a
Jeyne Poole's storyline so I'm just
expecting it to play out like that does
in the books one of the problems with
Game of Thrones as a show is that they
do everything so far in advance so if
there's something that just you know
everyone absolutely hates if they're
going to address it they have to wait
till the next season to do that so like
if everyone really hates what they've
done with Sansa's character and how they
kind of put her down so that they can
put this ramsey storyline to the
forefront like it's more of a ramsey
storyline than a Sansa storyline they
can't address that till season six so
whatever ends up happening - Sansa this
season it is set in stone given that
reek betrays her for Ramsey I think the
hope now is is that she'll take her fate
into her own hands like she'll do
something crazy to try and get
rid of Ramsay just a moment when Ramsay
casually showed her her servant woman
who had been flayed and hung up it was
just so horrifying and so casual - like
it's no big deal
I think he did that a little bit because
Sansa pissed him off with all the
bastard talk
I've been naturalized by Royal Decree
well yeah you got naturalized by another
bastard
Sansa isn't wrong and I think that
Ramsay now is probably gonna try and do
something about that baby inside fat
Walda there's a lot of people that feel
like Ramsay might be like the new
Joffrey of the series we'll see if it
doesn't end up playing out the exact
same way I mean I hope not that'd be
kind of predictable the only real bright
shining moment in all this is that Sansa
now knows that Jon Snow is doing just
fine he's Lord Commander she seemed
really surprised when Ramsay mentioned
him I don't think she's forgotten about
him I think just so much crap has
happened to her that she hasn't had time
to think about him she's mostly spending
her time trying to not get murdered
monster number five
Stannis's army is starting to fall apart
I like the shout out for the storm crows
in winter is coming it's just not a
stark saying it is literally coming
seriously like look how hard the snow is
blowing up at Winterfell just in those
normal scenes during the middle of the
day in the context of the series it kind
of already is early winter but when they
say you know winter is coming like in
the real final sense that means it's
snowing in King's Landing so I mean
we're still ways away from that the real
WTF here though is that Melisandre
suggests that they sacrifice Shireen and
nice dad that he is Stannis isn't
hearing any of it they've really been
positioning him is like the nice guy
this season he hugs his daughters he
complements people like Sam well he's
doing all kinds of stuff that you would
have never thought when you first saw
him season two was a real big Stannis
arc and he kind of seemed like an
[ __ ] during that season Ramsay isn't
wrong though Stannis just is not used to
fighting in heavy snow in Ramsay's
family the Bolton's they're totally used
to it so they had the advantage even
though Stannis has way more men I know
he said they lost five hundred men they
lost the stormcrows but they still have
a huge army on to number four the
continuing saga of Samwell and Gilly
Samwell is like the Millhouse of the
series so whenever he stood up to those
other brothers that were trying to rape
Gilly I just thought everything is
coming up millhouse and ghost hopped out
a little bit yeah I mean he probably
wouldn't been able to do that without
ghost but still this was like
badass samwell moment or the closest you
get to it like the moment when he killed
the white Walker Gilly tell Sam to
always take care of little Sam well no
matter what that's her baby you could
make as many taking care of little Sam
jokes as you want you know that with the
sex scene that they had but isn't it
funny how they reversed the roles in
this you know typically you know the
things that Gilly did would be something
done by a male on screen but Samwell in
this scene was kind of like the really
soft female character I just like the
way Game of Thrones plays with gender
roles like say you know Brienne and
Jaime had a scene like that she would
probably be the man and he would
probably be the woman
we can let tumblr pick that up and run
with it but I think Sam and giladhiz
relationship is the one of the most
genuine ones on the show one of the most
believable ones I usually don't get
really excited about stuff like that you
know but like Jaime and Brienne date you
know they have one of the most
compelling relationships too but you get
the sense that they're never gonna end
up together it's gonna be a really
tragic relationship Samwell Gilly on the
other hand feels like something that
might end up sticking but onto number
three the queen of thorns and
Littlefinger conspire to get rid of
Cersei every scene on this show is made
better by the presence of the queen of
thorns
she's like the MVP of this episode she
just like isn't having any [ __ ] from
anyone this week how surprised are you
that she admitted that they killed
Joffrey together we all knew it but it's
still a surprise to hear her say it out
loud just because there are so many ears
listening in King's Landing I guess
there aren't a lot of people floating
around Littlefinger's flesh market
nowadays since it's been trashed but
still she's taking a big risk being so
open I just love how honest they are
with each other you know even though
Littlefinger speaks in riddles I have a
gift for you the same gift I gave to
Cersei a beautiful young man obviously
he was talking about Lancel but just
just the way that they're so open with
each other we both have very
incriminating evidence on each other and
we have a common enemy so why don't we
work together really the most dangerous
threat that she has is to just cut the
grain off from King's Landing and try
and starve him out but the high Sparrow
answered that you're just by saying we
are the many we'll do whatever it takes
to get rid of the few meaning that all
he would need to do was just March all
the peasants on Highgarden
and take the grain so there's a lot of
big threats flying around and most of
them end up being empty really it seems
like the high Sparrow is now the most
powerful person in King's Landing wants
number two Daenerys and Tyrion meet for
the first time this is so much fun even
watching Tyrion in the slave market sell
himself he kind of got like the reversed
Joffrey slap when he suggested that they
pay him a wages of Freedman my have the
tables have turned the look of hope
though outdoors face the minute he heard
the word Queen he is so fun to see him
just kick everyone's ass in the stadium
the sequence of events was a little
predictable but I really did love like
that big jailer helping Tyrion now like
he was like okay fine here you go buddy
I'm gonna I'm gonna show you some mercy
as crazy as it is in slavers Bay right
now you know I think they still want you
to think of Daenerys is a good character
they want to associate that storyline
with the idea of mercy so I think we'll
continue to see people being charitable
to one another with it with a few
exceptions like the people that they
actually want you to think of as
villains the same things happening with
Stannis right now you know he'd never
hear of you sacrificing his daughter the
WTF look though on Daenerys his face was
so much fun like she's a deer caught in
the headlights she's like I don't know
what to do with this information now
Tyrion Lannister what's this all about
the ideas that Tyrion is going to help
her with her people problem in Mereen
he's a great source of wisdom Faris
isn't there but you know hopefully he'll
show up eventually and they'll have like
a real small council for Daenerys a
group of people that can give her the
advice she needs Daario is someone who's
really honest with her but he isn't
necessarily the smartest person for
managing a city
Daenerys isn't just in the middle of a
war right now you know he's great at
making war great infiltration small
special ops but he's no ruler so you
know taking his advice you know his
reverse red wedding idea could lead to
some really bad repercussions who else
felt like they heard the rains of
castamere playing softly in the
background when he suggested did she she
round up all the heads of the houses in
Mereen and killed them Daario might
still do something you know a little bit
crazy he sounds a little bit jealous at
the thought of her marrying his star
he's jealous in the books but you know I
think the show is doing something just a
little bit different with his character
but we finally have Tyrion with Daenerys
that's a huge freaking deal I feel like
it'll play out pretty good like it's not
gonna take some dramatic left turn but
finally my number one WTF moment so I
kinda like split this between the sand
snakes and broad with Cersei versus the
high Sparrow so I'll actually I'll talk
about sands thanks first never before
has everyone held their breath so much
as when
was sitting in that cell singing loudly
intense and asked him how he was feeling
she has the same knowledge of poisons as
her father oberyn martell obviously you
know he coded the [ __ ] out of his blade
whenever he was fighting the mountain he
got dosed with way more poison but you
know remember he's like three times the
size of bran so even just like a little
bit would have killed him almost
instantly and that kind of is what
happens I mean they weren't really clear
on the timeline like how long this
moment happens after he got nicked with
the blade but it seems like it's
relatively quickly I feel like they
should put that song on the soundtrack
though I've tasted the Dornish man's
wife I will say the mechanism by which
he got the antidote was a little
contrived I'm not really sure where
they're taking the San snakes this
season you know but tying you know just
like taking all her clothes off to tease
bran there might be something going on
there later this season he takes the
antidote so he I mean he's totally
sticking around but while that was
happening my eyes you know float it to
the background and you could see Obara
Nymeria just rolling their eyes into the
back of their heads given where their
arc is right now I don't see a whole lot
more fighting going on inside Dorne the
real question is is what is Prince Duran
going to do with Jamie because Jamie
doesn't want Marcela to stay and Prince
Duran doesn't sound like he's too hot on
the idea of Tristan marrying Marcela
really we'll have to see how this is
affected by what's going on with Cersei
in King's Landing because that'll
probably influence what Prince Doran
decides to do and finally it Cersei
versus high Sparrow so this was you know
one of the big moments as a book reader
I was waiting for I was so happy when it
finally went down Cersei is one of the
most smug characters on the books and
she's been an [ __ ] all season long so
watching the high Sparrow just choke the
hope out of her was so much fun
she was defiant to the last but the
moment her eyes started darting across
the room looking for you know whatever
he was talking about till Lancel walked
out that was so great sometimes some of
the best performances on the show are
ones that don't involve words you know
just people using facial expressions to
convey really strong emotions so much is
going on on Circe's face right now so
many things going through her head I'm
gonna go out on a limb and say she's
probably not gonna find the same mercy
from the mother that Loras and Margaery
might find it's gonna be such a fun
twist on the trial that Tyrion got last
season but we'll see if it plays out the
same
there's so much going on right now
there's so much stuff that's teeing up
the last couple of episodes here's my
big question what do you think is going
to happen when Cersei goes on trial and
do you think that John is going to end
up using that dragonglass dagger that
Samwell gave him it's been all season we
haven't seen a single white Walker I
feel like if we're going to it's gonna
happen up at hardhome
I feel like that dragonglass dagger is
gonna be used so I'll suggest in general
like the weakest storyline this week was
Sansa's just because it did nothing to
address what's going on with her like it
seems like a dead end at this point
unless she does something to save
herself she's gonna be like the damsel
in distress again for another season the
hope was that this year she would take a
darker turn and would start taking care
of herself
we still have three episodes for her to
do that so there is a chance that she
could turn around strongest storyline
this week obviously the high Sparrow he
is on a roll in King's Landing but the
MVP of the episode was the queen of
thorns she's not nearly as big a
presence in the books but Diana Rigg is
just so amazing with all these other
characters like her scenes with the high
Sparrow that was so much fun
I just hope that they get a couple more
of the season so just a quick reminder
I'm gonna do a Q&A tomorrow so ask all
your questions there's so much that we
have to talk about them this week I will
announce the winner of the giveaway in
that video if you have any requests for
next week's bonus video just let me know
in the comments so while you guys wait
for the Q&A you can click here to learn
all about maester aemon's history and
you can click here for last week's
episode thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tomorrow
you